[Applause]
all right everybody we have uh a lot to
do tonight great show you guys are
sounding good tonight before we go any
further though i want you all to uh
quickly say uh uh i always go out before
the show and say a quick hello to people
in the audience and i just met a
gentleman who fascinated me uh
he's he's from slovenia
and his name is his name is is his name
is veet is that correct veet is your
name feet
[Music]
[Applause]
i love how accepting this country is
people from all over you've instantly
become the most powerful person in
television
i'll say hi to my friend veets
from slovenia and vee told me he doesn't
watch the show uh nbc doesn't air the
show in slovenia but you watch us online
that's correct yeah yeah do you enjoy
the show it's great yeah i love it too
i'm a big fan
you seem thrilled
[Laughter]
well that's very nice so jeff uh isn't
this correct people can watch our show
online now as you get the word out about
that right
nbc.com
so just if you go on nbc.com and use a
credit card it's like eighty-eight
dollars
great
free free oh okay
i know there's a catch somewhere i've
worked for general electric for a long
time
it's free and then someone comes later
and hits you uh
i don't mean any of that it's a great
company
but um
but welcome veet welcome to our land and
i hope you have a good time did you come
who's a good guy beat i like these
i like feet pete's very cool and he's
like in touch with himself and
i didn't mean anything by that i just
mean you're a cool guy
himself all right lots to talk about
here a lot going on i got to say
something i don't know if you agree with
me here on this beat but it seems like
every time you turn the news on these
days especially in this country i don't
know it's like in slovenia but in this
country every time you turn on the
television in america uh they're
reporting about some new scandal isn't
that true every time you turn on the tv
celebrities breaking
[Laughter]
are we gonna weigh in with veet on
everything tonight
slash was in guns n roses right v that
is correct
beats my man uh
anyway they're always reporting about
like celebrities breaking the law
politicians getting caught up in a sex
scandal a ceo embezzling money scandals
everywhere well i hate to admit it
ladies and gentlemen but we've had our
fair share of scandals here at our
little late night show
and i thought rather than let the media
find out and then run our name through
the mud it might be better if we aired
these scandals ourselves and a little
piece i'm going to call late night
scandals
[Applause]
[Music]
the first scandal is that graphic right
there
am i testing my breath is that what i'm
doing
all right
not a lot of scratch here at the show
well first of all here's a scanner
there's an ongoing scandal involving
china everyone knows about apparently
china's been flooding our country with
inferior goods that have been made with
toxic materials well i have something to
confess i'm not proud of this
before the show we customarily hand out
free late night t-shirts to our studio
audience to cut costs we had the
t-shirts made with illegal textiles in
china now hopefully none of you have put
these t-shirts on yet because before you
put them
[Applause]
okay that's
i i love veetz behind him doing his best
to make that joke funny
please get behind it
conan tries hard help him
our show
now that's really smoking and that
probably really is toxic
leave get out of here
all right well uh moving on i should
probably get on to the next game use me
conan
i've got a little scandal your fans
might like to hear about
oh hey everybody that's my former
assistant dana okay actually danny was
probably moving what's the matter conan
don't want our little secret to get out
afraid people might learn the truth
about mr goody two-shoes talk show host
okay i really don't know what you're
talking about yes
dude you liar
i'm talking about your illegal
volleyball smuggling operation
it's true it's true
they're just so much cheaper in mexico
by the way i'm pregnant oh good
here's another scandal i want to come
clean about i hate to admit this but for
many years we've been spraying our
studio audience with laughing gas
see when i spray the audience with
laughing gas it makes it a lot easier
than being genuinely funny
unfortunately it became obvious we were
using laughing gas during my recent
interview with documentary filmmaker ken
burns
take a look
in world war ii that generation they
never discussed they never discussed it
wasn't what you did and just think about
it too you turn these teenagers into
professional killers they see bad things
in some cases they do bad things
well our announcer joel goddard says he
has something he wants to share with us
conan have you ever heard rumors about a
certain deep dark secret scandal here at
late night
deep dark secret scandal no i don't
think so joel you mean you never heard
that one night several years ago when
the studio was dark and everyone had
gone home a certain employee here at
late night exposed himself to a janitor
and then when the janitor threatened to
report the employee the employee
panicked hit the janitor on the head
with an ashtray and buried him beneath
the floorboards of his windowless booth
and that now
the guilt-stricken murder is plagued day
and night by the deafening sound of the
dead janitor's heart the being of his
hideous heart
no joel i i never heard that story
then i guess it's just a roommate
well of course atlanta falcons
quarterback michael vick ruined his
career by getting involved in a dog
fighting scandal now dog fighting is a
terrible thing unfortunately the guys in
our band recently got caught up in
something far worse take a look
[Applause]
that's close
i will take a little break when we come
back dane cook's here stick around we'll
see in a minute